le prix spécial du jury disait georges
rigaud est allé à un metteur en scène
soul et tiken jah works qui pour son
film tibériade récompense de meilleur
interprète masculin jack lemmon pour son
rôle du film le syndrome chinois
meilleure interprète féminine sally
field au sa création norma rae
mais d'abord si période de crise
dans ce prix spécial du jury dans mon
cas ma caverne en mai pour le cinéma
soviétique à mon avis c'est à mon avis
c'est très important parce que il y a un
sur deux clichés du cinéma soviétique
doit être ou bien c'était sûr de
propagande ou bien c'était long c'est
ennuyeux et c'est pas du tout se
touchent pas et moi je voudrais je
voudrais toute ma vie consacrée pour des
transactions de clichés qui existent
malheureusement les lignes nettes et
fiscaux base aux intérêts à la machette
ils s'apercevraient lady cap ni sa
manière
sa tête est pleine
ils vont toujours celui qu'a connu
ne
jack lemmon c'est un rôle inhabituel
pour vous j'ai été très gâtée dans ma
carrière j'ai fait à la fois des
comédies et des rôles dramatiques mais
c'est le film dans lequel je me suis le
plus impliqué
le
je n'étais
ja
le
et puis
c'était
m
un peu faim
oui ce qui est normal et salif i think
nommerait y est c'est vraiment la nature
iccn test je me suis attaché
la mettre en évidence les vrais
problèmes de la vie de norma rae ses
enfants son existence qui est salie fils
de martin ritt sally field est vraiment
comme norma rae c'est une lutteuse c'est
une tigresse et c'est une actrice de
première classe à froid mais rares
voiles rodez en ce moment même le gala
de clôture parachève la fête du cinéma
avec la projection d'un film français
à nous deux de claude lelouch il faut
souhaiter que la qualité des films du
festival contribue à faire grossir les
rangs des spectateurs dans les salles et
stimule tous les créateurs